and let's get back now to our breaking
news out of afghanistan where at least
25 people have been killed
uh let's speak to affiliate control who
joins us live on the phone
from kabul uh philia tell me what more
you know
well you know nick the attack happened
around 5 30 p.m
kabul time this is the time when
students were finishing their classes
and we're heading home and we're talking
about hundreds of students attending
schools at that time
according to eyewitnesses there were
three explosions that happened
back to back at that time again this
according to eyewitnesses
and they were talking about girls who
were panicking they started running
around crying calling for their mothers
and as others were trying to transfer
as many as they could to hospitals and i
have to tell you even that
is an uphill battle here in kabul
because big parts of the city have been
without electricity for the second day
after isil attacked power lines and
claimed responsibility
there are already some extremely graphic
pictures uh from the area of the attack
going around with charred
bodies and school notebooks
carter scattered in the area of the
attack which happened in dust about
this is in western kabul which is a
predominantly hazara area with shias
an area that has seen many attacks in
recent years
and isil has claimed responsibility for
most of the mix
right yes we need to put this in context
of recent attacks and indeed the uh
ongoing u.s troop withdrawal
absolutely and we have to remember that
it was only a few days ago that there
was
another attack that bears some uh signs
of uh
what happened an hour ago that was in
rogar when there was this powerful track
bomb
uh that literally level levels because
we did go there and we did stick with
our own eyes
a guest house where dozens of high
school students were staying
and they were waiting to take their
university exam
so this is a very tense time and we see
that attacks
not only are increasing but the targets
now are
are high school students and innocent
civilians that are being killed
every single day in this dome attacks
nick
fili thanks for that uh filio control
there reporting from
kabul where at least 25 people have died
after multiple blasts in the capital
and explosions happened near a school as
she was reporting
in the area of dash de ebashi in western
couple we'll bring you more on that just
as soon as we get it